all right thank you for your patience
I'm back in town which means that good
movie movies and I always say it's hard
to go back to a previous weekend when
life in movies just keeps pressing
forward there's always something to talk
about this man but I would like to see
all eyes on me and review that for you
guys I make no promises we'll see what
happens that's in a perfect world for
now I saw 47 meters down - let's review
that first 47 meters down so 47 meters
down is the movie about these two girls
one of them played by Mandy Moore
they're on vacation in Mexico her
friends the exciting one of the two of
them her friends like hey let's just
shark diving I don't even know what it's
called you know when you're in the metal
cage like jaws and you look around
underwater and see sharks so they go and
do that this shady is two people you
could ever find clearly don't have
permits to do this and of course
something goes wrong and then BOOM their
cage with them inside sinks 47 meters
down to the bottom of the ocean they
have a limited amount of air and if they
get out of the cage the Sharks going to
come down and eat them what to do now
it's a survival movie a survival movie
that granted does have good moments of
tension but then it does get really old
really fast Lauren went into this movie
I was like two people trapped in the
cage at the bottom of the ocean could be
good then right before I sat down to
watch the movie I was like wait the
entirety of this movie is in fact two
people trapped in a cage in the bottom
of the ocean that could also be really
boring some good moments of tension
aside the movie is largely boring
because it's just that you're just
watching them in a cage looking what do
we do now granted the movie the shallows
which I did like is Blake Lively on a
rock for the entire movie but there is
more scenery there's more to look at I
don't like pitch blackness with a couple
of lights lighting the set and you're
always reminded about the shark that's
circling Blake Lively the sharks are
doing like the Sharks like I'm on
you right when you step
over there rock your mind and 47 meters
down there in the bottom of the ocean
and pitch blackness which is a give and
take I like the fact that if they ever
did venture out of the cage and the
shark didn't try to kill them it's very
disorienting it's like having a
blindfold on stepping out of a cage
walking ten feet spinning around to me
like okay which direction am I facing is
like I don't know they're only no
reference point I like moments of that
in this movie but really the fact that
there are sharks at all is just kind of
an inconvenience you know they're up
there but you don't really see them and
they kind of poke their head down there
if they really want to cause trouble
only happens a couple times where this
isn't Jaws with a shallow
the real threat is getting out of the
situation which does include sharks so
before you suffocate before you run out
of air the situation like this I feel
it's important to make the sharks a
character structure a concept but
they're not really in the forefront and
really the acting didn't floor me I mean
Blake Lively and the Shia hey don't want
to compare this to the shallows the
entire time sorry the fact is the
shadows really impress me Blake Lively
was surprisingly good in it is one Mandy
Moore I'm like ah okay a lot of
hyperventilating a lot of you know I
don't know I'm freaking out I'm dead did
you have a couple of girls in the bottom
of the ocean who were freaked out I
really I thought the ending was kind of
dumb I'm having a spoilt spoiler alert
let's be honest if you were going to
watch this movie you watched it last
weekend if you were going to watch this
movie and you still haven't you're a
large transformers we're going what is
it too little too late so I'm gonna
spoil the ending for you so many more
sister in the movie gets eaten killed by
a shark and it's very on the nose
fashioned Matthew Modine up there on the
boats like okay we have another oxygen
tank for you just so you know when you
switch oxygen tanks you could
hallucinate and you're like okay so
she's going to hallucinate that's what
they're telling me sure enough she finds
her sister again you're like that's
probably a hallucination burn her sister
go up they get saved and then she's
giggling and she notices the blood
coming out of her hand kind of looks
like it's still underwater is really
weird and then it shows her down in the
cage and then the coastguard comes and
rescues her and brings her up anyway
until she gets saved again so she
hallucinates getting saved with her
sister only to get saved by herself
showing that her sister actually did die
the way I think it would have been
better is she goes up with her sister
gets rescued and she sees the blood it
looks like it's underwater and then
she's down in the cage again like she
was and instead of the ill-equipped
Coast Guard coming in and rescuing her
having people like how are they warding
off sharks it looks pretty minimalist I
think sharks could eat them too instead
of having them save her she's just
giggling and then you hear her oxygen
guppy because she's out of oxygen the
camera backs up and she just suffocates
and dies thinking she got rescued that's
why you do a switch ending like that you
have to have a big reveal but have the
person either get hosed or have it be
different just kind of felt like a waste
at 9:47 meters down had a neat concept a
couple of neat moments of tension but
really the characters doesn't stand out
man anymore didn't really impress me
much in this movie the Sharks were kind
of heard about and talked about seeing a
couple times but they're not really in
the forefront movie was mostly boring in
the end they could have made the ending
better this is why I don't have a rating
system I just have factual phrases of
how I see a movie
is pretty forgettable so I'm not going
to remember this movie in t-minus two
days yeah already forgot all right guys
so 47 meters down have you seen it what
did you think about it or was your
favorite survivalist movie whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]